[APPLAUSE]
PAOLO SOARES: OK.
So I'm Paolo Soares, and
I'm a software engineer
at the AdWords Express
team at Google.
And today I wanted
to share with you
how we got to share around
50% of our client code
among the Flutter
and AngularDart apps.
And yeah, it doesn't
seem like much,
but I'm not including all
the Google infrastructure,
because if I did that, I'll
get this crazy high number,
and you'd not
believe me, so 50%.
Google has a lot of
apps, and few of them
you may not have heard of them.
They are AdWords
and AdWords Express.
Yes, there is an
AdWords Express,
and yes, they are different.
But they have some
things in common.
And two of them are,
they make a lot of money.
And the other thing is they
are built on AngularDart.
And they also have Android
and iOS native apps,
which means that we
have three code bases.
Awesome.
Awesome because I get to do
the same thing three times,
every single time,
and hate myself a lot.
So because we don't really
like hating ourselves,
we are constantly trying
to find ways to share
more code among those apps.
And Flutter came out.
And we were like,
this is awesome.
This is awesome because
first, Flutter doesn't--
OK, not going to use that word,
but Flutter is good instead not
like Android and iOS.
And it is an elegant,
efficient framework
that will let us have a truly
single code base for iOS
and [? native ?] apps.
And because Flutter is within--
you write Flutter
apps in Dart, we just
happen to have these
gigantic [INAUDIBLE]
lying around that
is within Dart.
So I thought, hmm,
maybe all I need
to do is import the model
from the Angular app
and pass that to
the Flutter app,
and go have a beer or
something, because I'll be done.
But of course, that's
not the case at all.
And that's not the case at
all for a lot of reasons,
but the important
reasons are first,
we cannot just import the
model, because in reality,
the business logic is
all over the place.
And we as software
engineers, we like
to think that all
apps are like this.
You have the UI,
you have the model,
and they have clear boundaries,
and the interactions
are simple and clear.
But in reality, you
don't really have that.
You may even start with
this, but over time, slowly
but surely, you get this.
And you may tell yourself, no,
that doesn't happen for me.
Well, you go to the
AngularDart website
and go to the getting started
tutorial, and you have this.
This is the main ad component.
It shows a list of heroes.
And that's very simple, right?
You have a list of heroes.
You can select a hero.
That's it.
Well, there's a bunch of
business logic on this thing.
The first thing is, it knows
how the heroes are fetched.
It knows how many
heroes can be selected.
Let's say I want
to change his app
to select more than one hero.
Now I have to change
the Angular application
and I have to change
the Flutter application.
And lastly, it knows that
to manually select a hero,
you have to change the selected
hero, which sounds redundant,
but it really isn't,
because in practice, you
need to do more stuff, usually.
So even this very simple
four line component
has this problem.
So yeah, you have no hope.
Second thing is, remember
that infrastructure
thing I talked about?
It was written for
the AngularDart app.
And because it was
written for web,
it relies on a
bunch of stuff that
is not available with Flutter.
For example, like
the browser window
to get the correct
location, or the JavaScript
context to do some caching
or event [? pass. ?]
And it doesn't seem like much.
I mean, you could say
just rewrite those things
and be good.
But turns out that our
infrastructure is quite big,
and it has a ton of stuff
that we actually want
to use for many, many reasons.
Among them, API clients, crash
and performance monitoring,
activity tracking,
and some secret sauce.
And if I want to launch
this thing before 2050,
I should not be writing stuff.
So OK, we can't just
use infrastructure.
That's bad.
And lastly, we can't
just import the model,
because yes, Flutter is magic.
But you know what?
Angular is more magic.
[APPLAUSE]
And it all boils down
to state management.
In AngularDart, you
don't really need
to bother about what
happens when state changes.
It magically, sort
of not really,
it magically [INAUDIBLE]
update things for you.
But Flutter tells
you, you know what?
We need to be efficient.
And if you want to
be efficient, you
need to call set
state, basically.
And again, the model
was implemented
for AngularDart app.
And that means that
whatever interface it has,
it is not optimized
for this use case.
So now I have to write adapters
to wrap the Angular model,
and I'm going to have
this bloated Flutter app,
and I'm going to
hate myself again.
And this time it's going
to be my fault. On no.
Hopes dashed.
But hey.
[LAUGHTER]
Look on the bright side.
We get to do some refactoring.
And we as software engineers,
we love refactoring,
because our code
is always awesome,
and the other people's
code is not awesome.
So by definition, when
I rewrite something,
it's going to be better.
[LAUGHTER]
But we cannot rewrite
everything from scratch.
So oh no, we have to live with
other people's code somehow.
So what I am going to
do now is I'm going
to go through the Flutter app.
And I'm going to use
Flutter instead of Angular
because set state.
So whatever we do, it has to
be compatible with Flutter.
And then let's see
what I have to do
to get this thing working.
And I make a mistake
of live coding.
OK, so I have this
app called Purrveyor.
Is a search engine for cats.
It is a heavily untapped
market that we really
need to do something about.
So here you can search
for basically what, tuna?
And then you get a
list of search results,
right like non-GMO
tuna, organic, less fat.
So this is a very simple app.
Oh, the font is too small.
Let's see.
Preferences, Fonts.
4, Apply.
That better?
OK.
So let's [INAUDIBLE]
like the tuna, the fish
box, and the results.
So we have the stateful widget.
And I'll tell you why
it is stateful soon.
And it is very simple.
You build the input.
You build the preamble, which
is that this string results
for tuna.
And you build the results.
And the way you build
the input is you
have this search query input
widget that takes on change.
And then you change the query.
You have to update the query.
And you search as you type,
so you perform search.
And you build the preamble by
just interpolating the query
with the results for string.
And you build the results by
just mapping the create column
with mapping the results
to search result widget.
So that looks really clean.
That looks OK-ish, but
that doesn't cut it.
Because, again, that's a
bunch of business logic here.
It knows, for example, by having
this perform search on change,
you're incorporating
this knowledge
that search happens as you type.
And by having this
preamble here,
the widget knows how
to build the preamble.
So again, I think
that the [INAUDIBLE]
is like, if you want to
change something on the app
and have to change it
at two places, that
shouldn't be two places.
They should be at
the same place.
It's probably business logic.
So that's the case
for the preamble.
So if you needed to change
the preamble for the Flutter
and AngularDart apps,
with this design,
you need to change both of them.
So yeah, no, right?
And build results seems OK.
Nothing bad happening
here, I guess.
And perform search
is really bad.
Again, because it knows
that you have to use
an API to search the results.
And when the results get
there, you have to set state.
And we still have
this stuff here.
We have this binary API, which
doesn't exist in AngularDart.
And then you have to keep track
of the query in the search
results.
And similarly, if you
have data in two places,
like let's say we extract
these to business logic class.
But now this data
is in two places.
You have to maintain the
create query on the widget,
and maintain the create
query on the business logic.
Now you have data in two places.
And believe me, they're
going to get out of sync,
and it's going to be really
awful to track that down.
I've been there multiple times.
So yeah, this is bad.
This looks sort of
OK, but it is bad.
So one exercise
I like to do when
I'm trying to refactor or
redesign the API is I go here
and I just start throwing
stuff away and rewriting stuff.
And it's not going
to build, of course.
I hope so.
It shouldn't build.
And basically, I
just want to see how
I want the code to look like.
And then from there, I try
to make it actually happen.
So OK, I don't like the
API, these variables here.
I will remove them.
I don't like this that I have
to do the perform session query.
So let's say I have this
business logic class,
and then I do on
text on query change.
And when viewed in
the preamble, again,
I just have this
business logic class.
And I've got the
preamble before that.
And I also get the results
on the business logic.
And that means that I don't
need to have these anymore.
The widget doesn't know
how to perform the search.
And see, it is
much more concise.
And let's say I have this class
called search business logic.
That looks better.
That looks better
because now, basically,
the widget is really dumb.
It doesn't do anything
besides just display the data.
And if I went to
change, for example,
how the preamble is
built, I can just
change on the business
logic, and it's
going to magically work in
both Angular and Flutter.
But yeah, this doesn't
compile, so it's useless.
So you know what
I'm going to do?
I'm going to just
delete it and ignore it.
And I'm going here
and, yeah, I know.
I don't use this thing.
Let's do this.
And did someone tell you
that autoload is awesome?
This is awesome.
I just change the
heading, just works.
Crazy.
OK, so this is gone.
So let's try to make
this thing work.
This is basically the
same code, more or less.
And then I moved everything
to the search business logic
class.
And it keeps track of the query,
it keeps track of the results,
it builds the preamble,
and it updates
the query when you
perform the search,
so the preamble is updated.
And I don't know if you
folks, how many of you
have actually any
Flutter experience?
The last 24 hours also count.
OK, that's good.
All right.
So I'm [INAUDIBLE] but
maybe you won't see.
But this will not work.
And this will not work because
even though I am performing
the operations on
the business logic,
I have to update the state
on the Flutter widget,
or else it won't be built.
So really what I
need to do here is
I need to change-- this
is so beautiful, but yeah,
I have to get rid of it.
I love [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so I have to change this.
So when I perform search,
when the text changes,
I perform search.
So passing the query.
Then going to do
this awesome thing.
Set state passing nothing.
What?
OK, I'll wait.
I'm using future or.
So the advice here is to not
change your code five minutes
before the presentation.
I think [INAUDIBLE].
And then set state.
And again, because I changed
this thing five minutes ago,
it should work.
Please, God.
Yes, it does.
[APPLAUSE]
Right?
This is awesome.
This still looks
mostly the same,
but I just have this thing
here which, come on, really?
No.
Whenever you see set
state passing nothing,
that's a bad thing.
That means that you're
flagging the widget
to be rebuilt when
actually nothing changes.
And please don't
do that, really.
So yeah, this is bad.
So what can we do from here?
So I think that
the problem here is
you have the input, the
query, that changes over time.
And based on that
input, you have
the results, and the preamble
that also change over time.
And one way of how
do you represent
things that change over
time in Flutter or in Dart?
With a stream.
Yeah, awesome.
[INAUDIBLE] awesome.
You should come here.
So streams.
So let's say, can I just
change these things to streams
and see how it looks like?
Sorry, the query is an input,
and the counterpart of a stream
is a sync.
I think you didn't
know about that.
And turns out that a string
controller is a sync.
And the results will be a
stream of search results.
And the preamble would
also be a stream of string.
And yeah, let's do empty.
So of course, it doesn't work.
Oh, now it doesn't even build.
Back to square zero.
So let's go step by step.
I need to update the query
every time the input changes.
So that means I have to
do business logic dot
query dot add.
Oh, now I can use
[INAUDIBLE] again.
I'm happy.
But now I have this pickle here.
Text is string.
Preamble is a stream.
And async is not
going to save me.
Oh no.
But what if I had something
that I could have a stream,
and I could pass it a builder,
and it builds something.
There is something
called StreamBuilder,
which does a little of that.
This is more?
OK.
And a stream builder is
something that takes a stream,
and in this case it
could be the preamble,
and it takes a builder--
stream, builder.
And this builder
takes a context.
And it takes a snapshot.
But Paolo, what is a snapshot?
A snapshot is the last known
state of the stream, sort of.
I need to do another
talk about that.
And it has something called
data, which is not null
when there is data.
So if we don't have any
data, don't show anything.
And here we have the same
problem on the results.
I have to wrap this
with a stream builder.
And this takes a stream.
It's going to be the
business logic dot results.
And then this has
to be a builder.
Hey, [INAUDIBLE] people,
this should be automatic.
And then from the snapshot,
I map this snapshot.
Or empty if there is no data.
Oh yeah, so about that.
GGG.
OK, that's something.
Yeah, I have fat
fingers over here.
But anyway, let's ignore the
fact that it doesn't compile,
because it's not going to
work anyway, because it's not
doing anything.
But let's look at
the final code.
And I promise that I have
a working example, I guess.
No.
So now I can [INAUDIBLE].
It's awesome.
It's very simple.
I can directly pass in the
data to the business logic.
And I don't need
to wrap the results
in anything too complex.
I mean, they are going to
be async one day anyway.
And StreamBuilder is
something provided by Flutter,
and it is [INAUDIBLE].
So this still looks
pretty clean and close
to what I wanted it to be,
besides the StreamBuilder
stuff.
So yeah, but you don't
believe me, right?
This does work.
That's why I have another file.
I have many files.
So I have [INAUDIBLE] and hot
reload because it is awesome.
And then, yeah.
Let's go to [INAUDIBLE],, because
you still don't believe me.
It could be the other
thing you just copy paste.
This is too small.
Also IntelliJ should scale.
So this is the [INAUDIBLE]
implementation,
which is basically
the same thing.
You add and have StreamBuilders.
And you have the search
business logic here.
Oh, one last thing.
You know the binary API?
That has to go away.
So the modus operi
for that is that you
strike this
cross-platform interface,
and you inject the
implementation.
You have a binary
implementation for Flutter
and a JSON implementation
for AngularDart.
And then we have this--
so injected like this.
Not exactly like
this, but like this.
We create a search BLoC.
And what is a BLoC?
Suspense.
And if you folks want to see
how I implemented this thing,
its really simple.
It's like it's
reactive [INAUDIBLE]..
Anyway, I did too much already.
So yeah, so that's how
I want it to look like.
And that was a
process, more or less.
There was lot more
tears in this process,
but that's what we got to.
And let's go back
to these lights.
And they say, OK, Paolo,
that's awesome and all,
but you didn't say
anything about Angular,
and you know that 90% of us
care more about the Angular
than Flutter.
OK, fine.
Let's say you have this
search screen component,
and the only thing it
would have would be
the BLoC or the business logic.
And then if you had the
template that when you search--
you have a material input
that when it changes,
it sends the event
to the component,
and then just shows the
preamble and the results.
There is something
called a async pipe
that lets you do this.
So instead of calling a
method on the component,
you directly add to the BLoC.
And instead of showing
properties from the component,
you access these
strings from the BLoC.
And what the async
pipe you do, it
lets you use a stream
as if it was a property.
So your Angular code, yeah,
you had to add some characters.
But come on, that's good.
So good.
So we have this pattern now.
We have this class.
Oh, I have this thing now.
So we have this class.
When we are refactoring, we
extract the business logic
to this class.
And it has a well
defined set of inputs,
and a well defined
set of outputs.
And if you happen
to have any platform
dependent dependencies, you have
to extract a common interface
and then inject the
different implementations.
Nice, right?
But there's a thing.
If you don't give it a name,
especially with an acronym,
people are not going to use it.
So we gave it a name.
We called it BLoC, which
is the Business Logic
Components, like the building
blocks of application.
Yeah, I know, it's right there.
But we had to name it.
So good.
So we went from this to this.
But Paolo, you might
ask me, because there's
no Q&A, but Paolo,
you may ask me,
the whole point
of a presentation
was that over time, things are
going to get more complicated.
So how do you prevent
this from happening again?
Because it has happened before,
and it will happen again.
Well, some good old
aggressively pedantic rules.
And basically, we have
a set of guidelines.
And if you don't follow
them, you are wrong,
and there's no negotiation.
That's the best set of rules.
All right, so the guidelines
for designing your BLoC are,
number one, the
inputs and outputs
are simple, streams and sinks.
You cannot have platform
dependent concepts
and constructs.
That's kind of obvious.
But the inputs and
outputs are only streams.
Can I have a function?
No.
Can I have a [INAUDIBLE]?
Sinks, streams.
Second, dependencies
must be injectable,
and if you don't do that, you
have more trouble than this.
And they have to be
platform agnostic.
And by that I mean, the
interface you inject
doesn't have to depend
on Flutter or Angular
or any concept
like, for example,
having a browser window.
Third, inside the BLoC, you
cannot branch on platform.
You cannot have if mobile do
this, if AngularDart do that.
Because again, when
you start doing that,
that's a rabbit hole that's
going to make your code much
harder to track.
And lastly, if you follow
the rules number one, two,
and three, you can
do whatever you want.
You can implement your BLoC
using imperative programming.
You can problem using
functional programming.
You can program it
using smoke signals.
I don't care.
Just follow the three rules.
But may I suggest you
try reactive programming
in these trying times.
So we have guidelines
for designing a BLoC,
but we also need guidelines
for designing UI.
And those are there is a more
or less one-to-one pairing
between UI component
and widget in a BLoC.
So in this case, we would
have a search screen BLoC.
And of course, you're not
going to create the BLoC
to every single widget,
especially Flutter.
Yeah, you don't want that.
So you have to make
a judgment call.
And that's OK.
You have to define
what complex enough is
and what makes sense
for you and create
a BLoC for each widget
that is complex enough.
Second, components should
send inputs as they are.
If you have a BLoC
that takes inputs
that we present
as text field, you
are going to hook up
that on change directly.
You are not doing anything else.
Because the moment
you start doing
stuff, that's business logic.
You actually don't do anything.
And the counterpart
for this rule
is outputs should be displayed
as close to as is as possible.
And you're going to
say, but Paolo, you just
said that there
is no compromise.
And I'm not a savage.
I know that sometimes,
for example,
in Flutter if you want a
[INAUDIBLE] text, a style text,
you have to somehow
massage the text.
But it should be as
clear as possible.
You should not add anything
[INAUDIBLE] anything.
If you're going to display
an amount in dollars
and you want to format that, you
do not format that in Flutter.
You format that on the BLoC.
And lastly, if you
have any branch,
and again, I'm not a savage.
Sometimes you need to
do it inside a widget.
That's fine.
But that if can only have one
condition, and that condition
is a BLoC output.
One BLoC output.
Because the moment you start
doing ands, like BLoC output
A and B, the fact that you
need to merge those two, that
is also business logic.
So to wrap it up, that's
kind of obvious, bu
you have to move
all your business
logic to BLoCs following that
pattern that I just said,
that I just showed.
Secondly, you have to
keep UI components simple.
Because the moment you
start making them complex
or making them think
for themselves,
then things get complicated.
And lastly, design rules
are not negotiable.
And that's for the
sanity of everyone.
So with that, I say thanks, and
I hope that's useful for you
folks.
[APPLAUSE]